yo welcome to my crib
this is my family they're setting up
right now we'll take you on a little
trip let's go
[Music]
so you know we just got a little setup
right now this is the living room so we
kick back and watch tv
you know board games all of our black
art look at this
[Music]
this is where we do the morning
breakfast scene from the original the
iconic wrestling scene it all happens
right here on this table and all this
black art man it's amazing
wow then we got the kitchen this is
where hillary does all of her cooking
got some fruits
right here you know i can do a little
judgment
our fridge is functioning so anytime i'm
hungry on set
just go in here
you know
pop open the collard green up
get busy what i'm saying got all of this
look at all the pantry
this is the detail that goes into the
set of bel air right this is a lived-in
house the whole experience you know what
i mean look at that right there boom
doesn't it feel like there's been kids
like just eating breakfast here every
morning for the past 12 years
cups right
like why do we need those cups it's
called detail it's called storytelling
that's how you tell the story about it
what's good welcome to my dressing room
come on in not gonna lie it's a little
boring because i'm really really bad at
decorating these these cute little
things
actually this was day like negative one
because this was before we started
filming i did not know what was coming
and then after that my life kind of
changed a little bit i have my air pods
for whenever we're doing uh emotional
scenes and carlton needs to you know go
somewhere nice and low music is kind of
my
avenue into any of the emotional stuff
that i got to do so i always always have
these with me and that way i can lock in
and zone in when i need to i have a film
camera because my sister she's like an
artsy gal and she was like ollie i want
you to do me a huge favor um i want you
to buy a film camera
okay um i want you to buy a phone camera
and you know take a picture of
everything you're doing and document it
um because she was like i'd love to do
an exhibit of this one day
i did that for about two weeks uh and
you know actually let's take a picture
right now come here come on let's stand
stand right here and this would be like
a cool little
and yeah that's the trailer
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to my crib this is uh this is
the office
this is where i get all the work done
this is what we do when we want to save
money on heat
we don't turn up the
thermostat
as you can see
i'm uh i'm the house manager at the
moment so uh
i'm managing the house
[Music]
welcome
to the leisure room of bel air yeah this
is where we uh we could chill and do
leisurely things thanks
he said he wanted a massage
good room good room good memory it's
quite good
love this couch i remember when i was
four
and mom and dad brought home this couch
for the first time you remember that
[Applause]
yo what's up welcome to the hair trailer
um we've got ursula here introduce
yourself what do you do hi i'm ursula
simpson i do hair with the hair
department for bel air for season one
one this is where all the magic happens
you know we got all of the hair products
and stuff that make the black hair pop
and shine on screen look at the clippers
hey do you need me i'll give you a
lineup oh no please
watch i'm about to ruin season one
this is how it happens this is why we
call it the love trailer but they have a
little collage of all of our features
and these are all like continuity yeah
you know what i mean that's how they
keep themselves on track from episode to
episode and they'll give me a whole
collection it's really interesting to
look at some of these and remember the
days that they were taken right
i think this was the first day that um
jj worked
now i'm getting all sad right now i'm
getting sad that's great and i think
it's because you know we're
we're nearing the end
you